양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Wattress이고 IBM
Quantum의 교육 기술 총괄 디렉터예요. 이번이 시리즈의 16번째이자 마지막 강의이고, 오늘 주제는 내결함성 양자
컴퓨팅이에요. 지난 세 강의에서 양자 오류 정정 코드의 여러 예시를 살펴봤는데요, 이 코드들은 오류가 너무 많이 발생하지 않는 한 양자 오류를 감지하고
정정할 수 있어요. 그런데 양자 컴퓨팅에 오류 정정을 실제로 적용하려면 아직 해결해야 할 문제들이 많이 있어요. 예를 들어, 우리가 쓰는 양자 gate, 측정, 그리고 상태
준비 자체가 불완전할 수 있다는 현실이 있죠. 예를 들어, 양자 오류 정정 코드로 인코딩된
하나 이상의 qubit에 오류 정정을 수행하려면, 그 자체로 오류가 생길 수 있는 gate와 측정을 사용해야 해요.
그 gate와 측정이 제대로 작동하지 않을 가능성이 있다는 뜻이에요. 그건 오류를 감지하거나 정정하지 못할 뿐만 아니라
새로운 오류를 도입할 수도 있다는 의미예요. 게다가 우리가 실제로 수행하고 싶은 계산도 완전하지 않은 gate로
실행해야 해요. 그리고 계산을 위해 양자 정보를 디코딩했다가
다시 인코딩하는 방식은 절대 쓸 수 없어요. 양자 오류 정정 코드의 보호가 없는 순간에 오류가 발생할 수 있거든요.
이 말은 양자 오류 정정 코드의 보호를 한 번도 벗어나지 않으면서 논리적 qubit에 직접 양자 gate를 수행하는 방법을 찾아야 한다는 뜻이에요.
굉장히 어려운 요구지만, 노이즈 수준이
특정 임계값 아래로 떨어지는 한, 노이즈가 있는 하드웨어로도 임의로 큰 양자 계산을 안정적으로 수행하는 것이 실제로 가능해요.
적어도 이론적으로는요. 이 아주 중요한 사실에 대해서는 강의 후반부에 다룰 거예요.
이번 강의의 간략한 개요를 살펴볼게요. 먼저 내결함성 양자 컴퓨팅의 기본 모델과 노이즈 모델에 대한 간략한 설명부터 시작해서,
양자 circuit을 내결함성 방식으로 구현하는 일반적인 방법론을 다룰 거예요.
그다음엔 내결함성 양자 circuit에서의 오류 전파 문제와 그것을
어떻게 제어할지 살펴볼 거예요. 특히, 오류 전파를 제어하는 아주 간단한 방법인 횡단적 gate 구현에 대해 이야기할 건데,
이 방법만으로는 해결할 수 없는 근본적인 한계도 있어요.
또한 소위 magic state를 이용하는 다른 방법론도 이야기할 텐데, 이건 오류 전파를 제어하는 또 다른 경로를 제공해요.
물론 이게 유일한 방법은 아니에요. 마지막으로 강의는
방금 잠깐 언급했던 임계값 정리에 대한 꽤 높은 수준의 논의로 마무리돼요.
이 정리는 모든 구성 요소의 오류율이 특정 유한한 임계값 아래로 떨어지는 한
임의로 큰 양자 circuit을 안정적으로 구현할 수 있다는 내용이에요. 일반적으로 이 임계값은
우리가 사용하는 오류 정정 코드와 내결함성 구현을 위한 구체적인 선택에 따라 달라지지만,
구현되는 circuit의 크기에는 영향을 받지 않아요. 이건 대규모
양자 계산이 언젠가는 현실이 될 거라고 믿을 충분한 이유가 돼요. 내결함성 양자
컴퓨팅의 기본 모델 이야기부터 시작할게요. 자연스럽게 양자 circuit과 양자 오류 정정 코드에 기반해요. 이 논의를 위해,
구현하고 싶은 양자 circuit이 하나 있다고 상상해 봐요. 여기 보이는 것처럼요.
이건 EBIT 준비를 포함한 텔레포테이션 circuit인데, 이 논의에서 세부 사항은 크게 중요하지 않아요.
어떤 다른 양자 circuit이라도 괜찮아요. 상태 준비, 유니터리
연산, 측정을 포함한 훨씬 더 큰 circuit을 상상해도 돼요.
이 circuit은 물론 이상적인 경우를 나타내고, 실제
구현은 완벽하지 않을 거예요. 자연스럽게 드는 질문은 뭐가
잘못될 수 있냐는 거예요. 사실 잘못될 수 있는 게 꽤 많아요. 예를 들어, 상태 초기화가 일반적으로
완벽하지 않을 거예요. 물론 유니터리 gate도 완벽하지 않고
측정도 마찬가지예요. 게다가 qubit 자체도 계산의 모든 순간에 노이즈, 특히 결어긋남에 취약해요.
qubit에 아무것도 하지 않고 그냥 양자 정보를 저장하고 있을 때도 마찬가지예요. 한마디로
거의 모든 게 잘못될 수 있어요. 하지만 한 가지 예외가 있어요. 아니면 적어도 일반적인 가정이 있는데,
관련된 고전적 계산은 아마 잘못되지 않을 거라는 거예요. 사실상
고전적 계산은 기본적으로 완벽하니까요. 예를 들어, 표면 코드 오류에 대한 수정을
계산하기 위해 고전적인 매칭 알고리즘을 실행하면, 이 고전적 계산이 잘못될 거라고 걱정할 필요는 없어요. 하지만 양자 정보를 직접
다루는 건 달라요. 물론, 다양한 오류 발생 확률을 연결할 수 있는 정확한 모델이 필요해요.
원한다면 현실을 최대한 반영하는 복잡한 모델을 만들 수도 있어요.
하지만 모델이 너무 복잡하면 다루기 어렵거나 불가능해지고, 흥미로운 결론을 이끌어내기 어려울 수 있어요.
사람들이 자주 고려하는 아주 단순한 노이즈 모델 중 하나는
독립적인 확률적 노이즈 모델인데요, 서로 다른 구성 요소에 영향을 미치는 오류나 결함이
다른 순간에, 즉 circuit의 다른 위치에서 독립적으로 발생한다는 모델이에요.
예를 들어, 모든 gate는 일정한 확률로 실패하고, 저장된 qubit에서는 단위 시간당 다른 확률로 비트 플립과 위상 플립이 발생한다고 볼 수 있어요.
하지만 가정은 서로 다른 오류 사이에 상관관계가 없다는 거예요.
이 모델에 반론을 제기할 수도 있어요. 오류 사이에 어느 정도 상관관계가 있을 가능성이 높으니까요.
예를 들어, 모든 qubit을 한 번에 날려버리는 치명적인 오류가 발생할 확률이 낮지만 있을 수도 있어요.
혹은 더 가능성 높은 경우로, 여러 구성 요소에 영향을 미치지만 특정 위치에 집중된 오류가 있을 수도 있어요.
이를 부정하는 사람은 없어요. 하지만 이 모델은 자연은 예측 불가능하지만 악의적이지는 않고
양자 계산을 의도적으로 망치려 하지 않는다는 아이디어를 나타내는 간단한 기준선이 돼요.
더 현실적이라고 볼 수 있는 다른 노이즈 모델들도 많이 고려돼요. 어떤 모델을 선택하든,
모델이 잘못된 방향으로 이끌고 작업 중인 시스템의 오류에 대해 새로운 것을 알게 되면,
자연스럽게 다른 오류 모델을 만들고 고려할 수 있어요. 다음으로,
양자 circuit을 내결함성 방식으로 구현하는 기본 전략을 살펴볼게요. 주어진
논리적 양자 circuit, 즉 실행하고 싶은 이상적인 양자 circuit을 생각해 봐요. 예를 들어, 앞서 본 것과 같은 circuit을 고려할 수 있는데,
내결함성 구현을 위한 공간이 좀 더 필요해서 조금 늘어난 버전이에요.